foreign
trust no one in the world of anime those
are indeed words of wisdom a lot of our
anime heroes have had The Misfortune of
suffering betrayal and abandonment but
guess what it's not the end of the world
it's these situations to give you a
better view of the world's reality and
it's what the brave harness to become
strong so if you're up for some anime
where the hero gets betrayed or
abandoned and Strikes Back against fate
with him turning op or even more op than
he already was in the process or
something of the like then you've come
to the right place today this is what
our list is going to be about I won't
keep you waiting so let's get the ball
rolling starting off is unlimited
psychic Squad
here's a niche title to get things going
unlimited psychic squads a spin-off of
another show psychic Squad however
unlimited psychic Squad takes place from
the perspective of kyosuke hobo leader
of pandra and the major antagonist in
the original series in a directorial
Twist that's a preview of what's to come
with Hollywood and their long line of
movies starring the bad guy as the
protagonist this is the story where we
see how kyosuke's organization pandra
came to be he's already one of the most
powerful espers but as we all know the
ones at the top are the same guys ripe
for betrayal within being branded a
fugitive he sets forth to rescue other
mistreated espers gaining their loyalty
in his efforts to bite back against the
world psychic squad's family-oriented
atmosphere gives way to the dark
atmosphere as we look at the Journey of
an anti-hero watches rise from betrayal
to becoming the one who'll soon threaten
the world
next up is a new kid on the Block I'm
quitting heroing
if you're looking for something more
modern then Standalone this I'm quitting
heroing from just a season ago this time
our hero is Leo demonheart after saving
the world and ending demon queen
echidna's Invasion he finds himself the
subject of Scorn the problem is just too
strong and could end up being a threat
to humanity so it's time to switch sides
despite the rocky stop Leo manages to
find himself amongst echidna's ranks
with the help of her four generals
taking on a new identity he starts
working his magic within the Army
however he does have a major reason to
join the Army a concern that's been
bugging him for the longest time knowing
the reasons behind Echidna starting the
first war because surely no one wants to
be fighting in the first place right
kimono Jihan comes in next
appearances can be deceiving but not in
some cases one look at gabane can
confirm that he does give the impression
of a neglected and unwanted child being
left working in the fields and the rest
of the villagers wanting nothing to do
with him but he could also end up being
the greatest asset for a cart detective
gohachi inugami who arrives at the
Village to investigate a case of
Disappearing livestock corpses it's this
investigation that will lead inugami to
the world of the beast-like entities
that live amongst humans the kimono and
it's this boy who ends up being his
greatest asset abandoned and resented by
the villagers gohachi could end up being
the most important key to facilitate our
detective's investigation
[Music]
foreign
assassin was a surprisingly good show in
its season
[Music]
the world's finest assassin has no Pier
on Earth mercilessly killing for an
organization he meets his demise in the
only way possible in the form of a
betrayal betrayed by his own masters and
carrying regrets and resentment with him
he finds himself facing a goddess who
gives him a second chance at life citing
his expertise the goddess had
specifically chosen him to carry his
skill onto the next line for the
daunting task at hand the world's in
danger due to a renegade hero and he
must use his abilities in life to stop
said hero and save the world
reincarnated as the noble son Luke he
begins to learn about the world of
swords and magic with a second chance in
a New Direction at life he begins honing
his skills with his Newfound comrades
settling for nothing short of perfection
after all fighting the hero will require
nothing less and failure to do so will
result in his second demise
whether a hero is betrayed or ostracized
he would require all the help available
to rise through the ranks and strike
against cruel fate while it's not
anything as dramatic of the sword Vinnie
tube would like all the help we can get
so if you've liked what you've seen so
far please like and share the video and
hit that subscribe button because with
your help I'm sure that we're going to
be able to take the channel to new
heights we proceed to a perennial
favorite the rising of The Shield hero
[Music]
when it comes to stories where someone
Rises up from being betrayed or
abandoned by the rest of society the
writing of The Shield hero is probably
the first title to pop up in anyone's
mind you know what this one's all about
four Heroes get summoned to Mellow Mark
a country plagued by the waves of
monsters that have pretty much destroyed
its land for years each of them is
bestowed with a weapon to help repel
these waves however now fumi ends up
getting the short end of the stick not
only does he get a shield his first
adventure with mine ends up in disaster
making him Public Enemy Number One but a
setback like this isn't the end believe
it or not and now for me is left to go
through a journey of rebuilding the
nation's trust along the way he
purchases the raccoon slave girl
raftania who could possibly be the key
to saving the little good that's left in
his betrayed heart together the two
fights protect the kingdom despite their
reputations
[Applause]
and we can't talk about Shield hero
without proceeding to Ari fioreta
Ari fioretta just like Shield hero is an
isakai title that features someone being
betrayed and coming back strong however
I feared that takes the power fantasy in
edgy aspects of Shield hero can then
sends it into overdrive Arif Stars
Hajime who gets summoned to another
world with the rest of his class stuck
with a supposedly terrible ability and
being the subject of scorn and envy
Hajime is ripe for the picking and it
doesn't take too long before his
classmates send him on a one-way trip to
his demise the joke's on them though
because it's in that Abyss that Hajime
finds the secret to becoming strong
after rescuing the vampire UA and
gaining unimaginable power Hajime sets
forth to clear the Dungeons and unearth
the conspiracy behind the world and the
secrets of the dungeon creators
kite
we then have another overpowered hero
show something more vintage in stigma of
the Wind
gazuma can be seen as something of a
prodigal son of sorts due to his
inability to control fire and defeat at
the hands of his cousin Ayano he had to
endure exile for four years returning to
the garnagi household he discovers that
things have changed quite a bit as the
mass murder thing going on for one more
importantly the members have been
murdered by wind powers something that
gazuma ironically specializes in this
unsurprisingly leads to garzuma being
the number one culprit now he must deal
with Ayana once again both to clear his
name and to get to the bottom of the
murders now that's easier said than done
however with his partner being the one
relative that is not exactly on good
terms with how will the op hero and his
fiery cousin coexist battles comedy and
a lot of Showcases of power weight in
this one long time favorite Tower of God
makes an appearance here
[Music]
Tower of God is the first and arguably
the best amongst the three webtoons that
made the anime debuts in 2020 at least
if we're talking about the adaptation
Tower of God tells of bomb for most of
his life bomb only knew of a life
sitting in the depths of a dark cave
however his encounter with a girl named
Rachel changes everything in the process
of becoming friends with her Farm learns
about the outside world and a tower that
she leaves him for with his one friend
gone bomb now has a purpose in his
formerly Meandering life he has to go
and catch up to Rachel and set his
sights on the tower however in the tower
is a world Beyond his wildest
imaginations and he must be at the top
of his game to survive the perils that
lie within it each floor of the tower
sends him to a brand new adventure each
with challenges greater than the
previous one but with his side set on
Rachel nothing will stop bom and his
unshakable will
finally we close out this list with
another personal favorite doraro
a classic that's since become one of my
favorite modern remakes Doro is the
story of yakimaru yakimaru was born a
child with literally nothing and this
was all thanks to his father's packed
with the demons no limbs no nose no eyes
I think you get the picture it's the
biggest human sacrifice there is and the
babies left to die abandoned and
helpless where there's a will there's a
way and there is indeed a way for
yakimaru to once again become whole but
fate would have it they get saved and
given Prosthetics to fight the demons to
regain his body parts he must defeat the
demons one by one if doing so seems like
a Monumental task a new twist gets put
in his journey as he meets and befriends
the young orphan doraro now the tale of
the two Castaways in their shared
adventure of survival and Redemption
begins
and that's about it for this list if
there is one takeaway it's these times
will prove the adage that what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger despite what
fate throws at them these characters
have overcome and I think that's a
pretty good message all things
considered don't you think so before
going I want to thank you for watching I
hope that you'll have a great day ahead
and I'll be seeing you again in the next
video goodbye